[Music]
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum how are you tom
welling kristen crook and i
have joined forces my um
one of my charities of choice is the
ronald mcdonald house los angeles as you
know i do movie nights and i haven't
been able to do those i try to
you know get dinners for families and
things like that and help you know ask
people to help me and
anyway omaze.com reunion is teamed up
with smallville so you can go
there to omaze.com it's omazee.com and
uh
donating you're a winner already but uh
if you're drawn you get to have a
virtual zoom or whatever the hell you do
with me
tom and kristen and we could talk about
everything
so that's gonna be fun so check that out
everybody's a winner um other
great organizations um you know helping
the homeless
is foodonfoot.org ask for rob danson
he's my buddy who's also in my band left
on laurel uh he's my guitarist
and uh he works for them and and he's
amazing and i'm a 99
club member so maybe you'll join more
than come and join me we've got
in the outros we've got a lot of good
stuff we got uh shout out to my patrons
we got
uh oh just a bunch of fun stuff well
i'll read a fan letter
i always like to read fan letters uh
tell you a little bit more about what's
going on in my life and your life
hopefully
although i can't hear you um but i hear
you
trust me i freaking hear you also the
inside of you store
inside of you online we're getting guest
i know you guys have been asking black
shirts cool new black shirts cool new
gray shirts cool new hoodies i've never
had a hoodie
so we got hoodies and a bunch of stuff
coming uh shout out to brandy edie
um for helping me out pretty good
weekend you know i've been watching a
lot of classic
classic movies i still do the horror
movie night with my friends
uh name drop you know john heater the
playing dynamite
uh he and i watch horror movies together
in fact we love horror movies so much
that we're like you know
uh and we're always bitching where have
all the good horror movies gone
but john and i thought we'd just do a
patreon exclusive
so it's john heater and myself the
podcast is called where have all the
good horror movies gone
we're gonna have it on patreon soon uh
my patreon
for inside you but michael rose mom is
uh is just kick-ass man what a great
community in fact i've been doing
youtube
private youtube live videos just with my
patrons
so it's a couple hundred of us and uh
it's a lot of fun a lot of people are
sort of uh
doing things differently for this whole
thing this whole
coronavirus quarantine stuff so uh you
know i like to check in with celebrities
or you know my grandmother who's the
biggest celebrity i checked in with her
last week for the dave bautista episode
great episode by the way thank you for
listening
thank you for watching thank you for
spreading the news
and um you know we did uh stephen amell
on the grant gustin
episode we did and now uh i'm waiting
for my good buddy
uh you know him from it
part two he was he had probably the
biggest part
um he was in the movie back in the day
with me
shadowhunters isaiah mustafa
just want to check in with my old buddy
lives around the corner i want to check
up see what he's doing see what he's up
to
i mean he's also the old spice guy so
he's probably got to keep his body
conditioned
although how many how many commercials
can he shoot right now i don't know
so let's talk to isaiah hey man thanks
for doing this we're doing these little
intros just catch up on my friends see
how they're doing so you know people are
quarantined and
you know everybody's doing their own
thing and keep trying to keep sane how
are you keep insane are you
is working out part of your regimen is
that is that how you keep it going
honestly man like
i think the the best or the easiest
thing for me was to just find a routine
like once i got into a routine it was
good
but uh you know you have those days
where you just you know you're you're
striving for normalcy so you're married
lisa is a wonderful lady now
do you is it hard during this where you
can't
you're always on top of each other you
like having somebody around um i do like
having somebody around i love how you
say like having somebody around us
as though like you know like she like i
just need somebody around
no like uh no but i do i do like having
my wife around
um but she has her own office i have my
own office we separate during the day
come back together sometime in the
evening to have my dinner so you know
it's it's nice
but i i gotta knock i gotta knock before
i go in their office because
that's like the rule just knock you know
porn is that why she watching porn in
there
i don't think so because the the audio
that i'm hearing
is um sounds like a business meeting but
unless they're doing business meeting
porn nowadays i really don't
see that happening hey uh let me ask you
real quick you missed shadowhunters ever
you ever miss it
um i missed the fans i miss the cast and
crew the people up in toronto and stuff
like you know
like just seeing those people every day
and stuff like that yeah
i miss it i i don't necessarily miss um
like i you know i mean i think everybody
would say that you probably said this
when you were on smallville like you
know
there's days where you're like man can
we do something fun with my storyline
can we do something different you know
um or can we you know can we can we get
a
more in-depth storyline you know i don't
know i i think the fans would agree to
agree with me that
that luke the character luke garroway
never really got his
due um so but then again i always say
this like
it wasn't the luke gearway show it was
about you know teenagers
with crazy superpowers he was just
facilitating so hey man
people loved you people loved you you
lived by the y a novel you died by the y
a novel you know what i'm saying
[Laughter]
how much do you miss acting how much you
miss work cause you know you were a big
movie it too
i mean yeah i miss it all the time i
think i'm i don't know like i'm
i don't know how other actors feel about
auditioning but i i love the audition
process like i actually love going in
meeting people and saying stuff like you
know i don't know
just just getting able to kind of work
in a room in front of people i i like
that process i don't know i just
there's something about it that i i did
because it's instant either it's instant
like
instant results you know whether you did
a good job or you know whether it's not
going any further that's true well look
man i love you
i don't want to keep you i told you just
to be a couple minutes when are you
gonna bring me back on the show that's
what i want to know
you like come back again [ __ ]
you can come back whenever you want to
come back what we're trying to do now is
because we've had some repeats we're
always trying to get new people but like
i have favorites you're my you're my boy
you know back in the day you haven't
seen back in the day he was great he
gained 30 pounds for the roll
man i gained 30 pounds like three weeks
ago almost like the first two weeks of
quarantine oh i picked up some weight
but it was crazy but you're still hot
even when you get heavy i'm a handsome
big man
i'm a handsome big man all right dude i
love you isaiah
thank you for joining me and i'll be
talking to you all right
i love that guy that was great all right
now let's get into our main guest and
remember
we'll uh we'll talk to you after if you
want to stick around for the outro if
you've got nothing better to do you want
to hang out with me
but uh let's get into this guy is pretty
dynamic he's fun i almost got him to say
a couple things but he was pretty open
and ah he's a good dude man
i really i liked him i genuinely uh like
him
this is uh let's get inside of justin
long it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael
rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
oh my god the poster uh i yeah i thought
about bringing a poster in here i have a
back to the future poster i don't know
what to do with it well
all right no here's the issue i just saw
that movie for the first time can you
believe that
what movie did you say the jerk you saw
for the first time
i know i know it was like the it was
such an embarrassing point of
embarrassment for so long
i never lied about it but i came close i
was so ashamed
that's so good uh and i and it was as
good as i
thought it would be it was better right
and
i was angry that it had taken me so long
first of all thank you for allowing me
to be inside of you justin uh yeah i'm a
little nervous about
being wait are you inside yeah you're
inside of me by the end uh things can
change up a little bit you know uh
it's funny how you start the first thing
you see is the jerk poster
i've had this conversation with a lot of
people and you know people come in the
house and then they see
posters and autographs and you know
they're like
odin kirk was really cool about he was
kind of fascinated by it
but you know guys like dax or mutual
friend dax he he doesn't
he never asks for autograph he doesn't
understand it he tries to get into my
psychology
i was like why do you need that why do
you think you need it yeah why do you
just what does that do for you kind of
is that what it is like why where you
need to
it is a strange thing autographs for
adults i think so you don't you don't
get that
um when i was a kid i remember really
wanting um
i got eric dickerson's autograph all
right friends
yeah uh eric dickerson the football
player the rams
and and it was funny because he said he
wrote uh
god bless eric dickerson and
i never really saw the comma it was a
black and white photo
and i was blessed himself as a kid i
just read it as god bless eric dickerson
i remember thinking like
well i mean he's great but he's sort of
conceited
now that he would write that but um
and at night at night you'd be going god
bless eric dickerson
that was your prayer every night i just
thought it went without saying i thought
god had already blessed him
obviously those great skills
you know god-given talent uh when i was
a kid i was really into the
an autograph as a thrill yeah and
certainly now
signing an autograph like a kid is such
a fla it's such a nice
thing you know it's um a few times it's
happened but it doesn't really happen
anymore now it's
everyone's got a camera on there wait a
minute justin you were in uh
galaxy quest and your character was like
seeking autographs and things i i don't
i don't understand you're not like your
character i you know what i
and this is very hypocritical i am like
because i now that i think about it i
have
i i have a signed flamingo kid poster
uh matt dillon my buddy mine got matt
dillon to sign it and that was cool it's
cool to
i got michael j fox to sign my secret of
my success poster so
i don't know what i'm talking about um i
yes somebody that i really admire um in
autograph would would be
cool i think i i've completely reversed
my position you've changed your mind
you know here's the thing with me you
got inside of me
and uh rewired me well you know i'm just
i i don't know what it is but like
especially with heroes that you grew up
watching oh yeah
when you meet them it's like like it's
not like i go on every movie set or
every tv show
but like i worked with stallone and
people know this and i waited till the
last day i knew that we our camaraderie
we had
that going we had he was like hey look
at you he called me dot face because i
like had these cgi dots on my face hello
look pippy longstocking
so i thought that's pretty good
what was he like what was it like
awesome
he was and i love this by the way
because you you have a show
life is short what's funny is like i
didn't get it at first the name was like
life is short and it was like weeks ago
life is short that's cool
no but i didn't no no i didn't realize i
didn't put it together with justin long
i'm an idiot
like life is short just it is it's
simple it's what it is it's like people
like
i found it was really hard to name the
show
something as simple as that it was
strangely complicated
we had lists um we do with this company
wondering and they had ideas and
to come up with that as as simple and
perhaps dumb as it sounds
that was believe it or not the best
thing that we came to after
a lot of deliberating we didn't
deliberate about many things about the
format about
you know what we the things we wanted to
talk about
but that title took forever to land on
well you know if you found that i did
and i think no matter what the title is
you're going to uh people are always
going to say oh
this that you just gotta go with like oh
this is cute this is charming i remember
um we had a clip that went viral and it
was on
stern and sturm was like uh he was going
oh this is a clip from uh inside of you
with michael rosenbaum oh it's like a
double entendre he's inside of you
ah and he's but heartbreaking but then
uh
uh robin was like oh we love him though
he's he was lex luthor and she's like
he's oh yeah yeah yeah because they used
to talk about that show all the time
but i was like come on i mean you know
he gives
everybody [ __ ] but uh yeah yeah it's
sort of like a badge it's kind of like
me i i got to
meet don rickles god rest his beautiful
funny soul um yeah i got to meet him and
he of course
uh he gave me [ __ ] and
all my friends he uh mocked all of us he
made fun of all of us and
threw around a couple slurs and um and
it was like
you i i expected it's what i expected
it's what i it's what you hope for when
you meet somebody like
absolutely when i'm on set you know so
when i went up stallone at the end i go
hey that's a wrap on me or whatever and
i go would you sign this rambo lunch box
you know and he's like you got a rainbow
lunch box
how old are you is it really is this for
you
and he signed it you know and he was uh
he was cool but it's just like it's one
of those things that
if i decide not to be an actor again you
know anymore if i
down the road i retire i move to some
little town like that's cool
and i got friends that come over from
the midwest and like ah dude slide sign
that
that's cool you know and by the way you
know you're doing a show
you're interviewing people i'm
interviewing people and so it's like
it's weird because i
i really love doing this and sometimes i
read the comments and everyone's going
to be like oh
oh you know sometimes you'll cut people
off or something
yeah because i get so excited do you
find yourself doing that where you just
get excited talking to someone
yes i'm very into um affirming things i
really like to affirm
uh yeah i get very yeah i get a little
over eager
i was noticing when i first started
hearing
uh the interviews played back i was
saying um
what was i saying oh it was weird i
can't remember now it was something like
uh okay or i was affirming too much
uh or maybe it was just yeah yeah yeah
it was a lot of that
yeah and i may still do it too much um
people who listen to the show
but i think i've gotten a little you
know you you learn over the you've been
doing this for a long time i'm sure
not that long i think it's like 100 and
something episodes 105 episodes but long
enough mike where you like
you you recognize certain things that
may even annoy you
that you didn't you previously didn't
know you i promise you this is the truth
i really almost never listened to my
myself once i'm done
i trust my i try and you know i notice
like people will say to me
man if you listen to yourself when you
first started interviewing people and
now
you have grown so much you're so much
better and i'm like oh
wait a minute how bad was i that's
that's what we think of yeah sort of a
backhanded
you may have just gotten more relaxed
and i happen to find
i like listening to criticism like that
you know especially
since this is something that's so new to
me um when it's obviously if it's like a
trolls if it's somebody just saying like
you suck and i
i hope you die i i you know that that's
different that's not like constructive
and
um but but people we've been
we also there's a facebook group of
people who listen to the show and they
often
um they they correct us i know that dax
you mentioned dax he has monica who
fact checks him but we don't really have
that and so i've noticed i've read
certain things
on instagram or whatever that um what
don't you like what have you read what
have you read that you didn't like
that i didn't like but you know that you
were kind of like [ __ ] that was kind
of like harsh
um
[Music]
well like hurtful things you know like
uh it's it's
it's usually it takes a lot these days
to really
hurt me i you know the funny thing
happened recently
where i i read um somebody just said
call me a dildo and they just said
you're a dildo which i kind of thought
was a little that was sort of funny it's
sort of a funny insult
uh to call a guy a deal though and um
and then
and i didn't respond to it but i and i
wasn't particularly hurt by it but i was
like oh that's weird that they would go
on
just so they would go through the
trouble of like logging onto their thing
and writing that and um
a couple weeks later somebody else said
you dildo and then they paid
they said a complimentary thing and i
realized it was um
your brother it was a reference to the
show i do called on the netflix this
animated show called episodes for family
where my character uses that word a lot
is
he calls his dad he's a teenager and
he's always saying you dildo
everything's effing dildo oh my god
you can curse um
and now i think the previous one that i
thought was a troll was uh
really maybe a fan of the show my
brother said well maybe he was both
maybe he thinks you're a dildo and
he's a fan of the show um i don't know
things that really hurt me
um i mean maybe in the past you could
reference something that something like
you know
was it were there was there time i'm
sure when like all those times when
you're dating drew and people are like
this and
i'm sure they said things that probably
hurt you you know mike
back then i didn't i didn't
read i think the the only way and this
is because my my
skin was probably a lot thinner and and
still probably would be too thin for
something
like a personal attack like that i uh i
didn't engage with it i didn't i wasn't
on social media really
i i if stories were in the tablets i
would hear about it usually through my
parents or friends or um but but
i found that that was an easy thing to
distance myself from that was an easy
thing to divorce myself from
it really was because it was really on
the internet or or
in those magazines and it's easy enough
to not read that stuff
you were loved as a child i could tell i
could tell you had a good relationship
you were loved as a child i was loved
yeah is that what we said
yeah did you have a good relationship
with your parents yeah very good yeah i
mean they drive
me nuts but they're by um
yeah they can be right now they're
frustrating because they keep wanting to
leave the house
and of course we're trying to you know
they're stubbornly wanting to go to the
grocery store and stuff
um but yeah they're very loving parents
i got i was
i'm very lucky so you had i always talk
about this because you know there's
certain things that
you know people out there they didn't
get this they didn't get that you know
and there's a time when you got to grow
up and [ __ ] and go hey you know i didn't
get that but i got to get it from
somewhere else and
that's kind of a thin line too because i
know that you know you don't get love at
home
you don't get hey you're good so what do
you do you go out you get it how do i
get it
right validation how do i get validated
so you never felt like
you always felt your parents are with
you i'm proud of you you're smart you
can do it they were always that
that was sort of the mentality yeah i
mean we we fell into i have two brothers
and we all fell into different
categories i would say and uh my older
brother was always the still as the
smart one i mean he was
he's brilliant and uh you know went to a
great school and was always ex
uh excelled academically and um
my thing i think was more the uh i was
kind of a
clown and oh i was very small for my age
so i
it was my way of finding um my social
footing i think was
was just being a a little clown
but i was also so small that i i wasn't
i was
like too easy of a target i i didn't
really
get picked on and i i wasn't threatening
enough to anyone
to to be singled out and picked on and i
so
i was okay socially um but i i think
maybe that's where i found any sort of
desire to to be an actor or to do what i
do now
uh how tall were you in high school i
going i can tell you exactly
going into high school i was four foot
ten i weighed 89 pounds
you two yep i graduated at 5'3 i grew
nine inches
after my senior year yeah i was the
smallest kid in high school small kid in
high school and
um yeah you just get overlooked yeah
yeah mike you were 5'3 graduating high
school yeah i didn't grow until i
graduated high school i graduated i'm
telling you i grew eight inches in the
next year and a half
oh my god i don't think i had hair in my
balls till i was a junior in high school
yeah i i'm trying i always i wish i had
chronicled
that development you know i wish i had
like written like a puberty journal like
when i had my first cube and like
i remember i remember do you remember
like getting like a hair under your arms
i was like dude
the [ __ ] is happening to me yeah well no
i used to pray for them
i would pray to god and uh eric
dickerson i'd say
please please uh bless good bless you
eric
give me something you wanted them oh my
god i wanted because skins and shirts
when you played basketball in indiana
everybody played basketball it's
something i didn't but i was like
i go you know what guys i'll sit on the
side because i didn't have any hair and
i'm like god forbid i had to take my
shirt off you're like dude
i remember mike curry lived down the
street and he used to go rosenbaum
where's your armpit hair do you not have
any armpit hair
and i go i remember going dude i swim
they make us shave them
because i had heard it or something it
was a comeback they're like what
you said you shaved him i swear to god
and my friend tom lolly will attest to
that
that's a more embarrassing lie i know i
always come up with these things that
are not better
just say uh uh yeah why you looking at
my armpit dude
mike mike carrie mike mike curry he had
dude he had enough hair for the entire
school he was his
kids oh yeah it was like like what
happened why does that guy get all the
hair
yeah but those are the guys that like
get all the hair in like eighth grade
and they
peak in like ninth or tenth grade a good
friend of mine he's not gonna want me to
say they might
you may know him uh really he wouldn't
he wouldn't care john pasani you know
pasani yeah i know john pasano
he was hairy he was hairy he was hairy
and like there were a few of those kids
maybe one or two that were like
fully haired like a full pelt you know
the head to toe
in like fifth grade and um
he said it scouts were they were
scouting him for college teams
in like fifth and sixth sixth grade he's
now like five
he's not that short but he's five eight
seven five eight he was that
high in fifth grade and um and he said
he never grew
after that so i and i knew a couple of
kids like that and i never it's funny
that you
were self-conscious about it because i i
i'm trying to remember now if i was i
don't remember that being
an issue for me i i was self-conscious
about like my looks and about certain
other aspects of my
physical appearance but um i don't
remember
the height being like really wanting to
be tall even though it was so tiny i was
so short maybe i did maybe did you get
girls do girls like you
in high school uh not really no not
um did you have sex in high school plays
what's that did you have sex in high
school
no no i was very uh i was a real late
bloomer in that department uh
no not until freshman year of college it
was when i went to a very
like progressive uh
i would say i guess all colleges like
this so i don't
i don't know if mine was particularly
sexual but um
it seemed that way it seemed like in
fact i think it was because
there was an article in spin magazine
spin magazine still exist
i don't know uh spin magazine where a
journalist went undercover
at the i went to vassar college and they
went undercover uh
and post as a student and basically
chronicled
how um you know sexual
the school what i don't know if i should
be saying um but it's
it's chronicled it's been already
written about i mean it's written but
yeah the
admissions shut up by like you know 200
are you serious based on that article
yeah yeah or
male um uh applications anyway
yeah and they were trying to even out
the female male ratio i remember
so it was uh by the time i got there i
think it was like
61 female still um i think now it's more
even
but uh it had been an all-female school
so they were trying to get more
which is probably how i got in because
it was easier for guys
right to get in do you hear that chair
oh it's pretty good
no i like that sounds like an egg but i
was grown by that i can't believe you
didn't grow
that's very rare mike it is rare and i
you know i think i i remember going into
the kitchen
one night and looking at my parents with
just tears in my eyes and going
this is your fault you did drugs
you always did drugs my dad's six five
my mom's like five eight i'm like why am
i
[ __ ] four foot or whatever and like
fresh me and like i remember i i
wrestled
and yeah i was like 14 and
oh and the reason is 13
wins were because there was no one light
enough to wrestle me
yes i was i wanted to play football so
badly and um the coach pulled me aside
at the end of this two-week training
training camp uh and he said
you know son we got a great wrestling
squad and i was like well that's gonna
be hard to do because i as you know
the wrestling season is the same as
football season and uh
and he goes son you're not going to play
you're not going to play on the team and
i say
i know i'll be on the bench i'll ride
the bench but i'm sure you know
god forbid someone gets injured and then
i'll go ahead and
back up and he said son let me put it
this way if the entire team
god forbid is on a bus this is not work
but he basically said if the whole team
is on a bus
and you happen to drive separately and
something happens to the bus
you're still not going to play uh and it
was heartbreaking
that is heartbreaking yeah so he was but
that's when he said he goes
you should wrestle we gotta go and he
said you'll probably be in your own
weight class
uh you'll be undefeated which is what
happened to you
and you you loved you like wrestling
didn't you host some wrestling thing
years ago at the staples center
um i did i no it's funny
i like wrestling no i don't i read
something about it i was like maybe lex
wrestling maybe he started wrestling in
high school or
uh no i did for a week and then i it's
too hard
it's too hard yeah um it's funny my
friend just connected me with i've been
wanting to do yoga and my friend paul
really great actor he was on the show
paul hauser was
has been doing yoga and he connected me
with this he's like you know i got a
friend who does it
and he's got his own app and he's got a
program and his name's
um dallas and so i was texting with this
guy dallas
uh dallas page and he told me to
download i know dallas page the wrestler
dallas page
he gave me a thing to download uh it's
called ddpy
yeah yes do you know it i do
yeah he's like but i had no idea it was
the wrestler diamond dallas page of
course i know who that is
and i've been asking him really
obnoxious because i'm so bad with
as you now know seeing how i've set this
up
took me so long to do this i'm really
bad with like computers and technology
and all that
and um i always it just made me laugh
that this whole time
i thought i was talking to like this
yoga geek you know this guy who
had this very peace peace loving
like buddhist-y yoga guy and i
clicked on the thing and it was like
this is diamond dallas pages yoga
get ready for your you know get ready to
align your chakras
it was um unexpected but uh
it's a good program you're into it you
know you you uh
just just watching and like and reading
about stuff and hearing some stories
like
i know you did uh obviously you did
dodgeball and i hear some stories like
you're kind of like a goofball i'm
always i'm a goofball on set i'm always
like always just trying to you know make
everybody laugh center of attention
just keep myself busy maybe because i'm
bored and like i worked with
you know one of my good friends is john
heater napoleon dynamite he worked with
you and he loved you
but he's like yeah he's always like uh
having fun he's always
do you guys awesome he's always like
cracking it yeah justin long's pretty
much all summer
yeah he's always like that's so much
energy or whatever
that's really good do you uh do you feel
like were you a kid who had add do you
feel like
were you all over the place were you uh
like i have atd there's no doubt about
it
squirrel squirrel do you not have that
you think uh
yeah i definitely have that definitely
happened i was um
how much of that do you uh do you think
was because you were little though and
you were trying to
get attention prove yourself find your
you know i think it was just like i
wanted
something like scott i'm too small i'm
not getting uh
you know i didn't get attention from my
parents really i was just sort of like i
need i need
girls girls no girls didn't like me i
didn't get laid
till i think i was 18. um yeah
but but i remember just always like i
guess when somebody told me i was funny
and that changed my life and i was like
okay i gotta be funny i gotta be on i
gotta be somebody else
so i think that that's why i always on
set i had an uh
a friend of mine once he worked on on
smallville with me and he goes
dude i don't know how you do it man i go
what he goes you're working like 14
hour days and you're doing learning
these lines and stuff and you're running
around saying
you never go to your trailer and just
chill maybe you wouldn't be so tired all
the time if you just went to your
trailer and just
relaxed you know mike i used to be like
that i i i know exactly what you're
talking about
because i love to be and i still do i
love being on set i love the energy of a
set
um god how much do you miss that now uh
yeah but
but um i found the older i got i i
needed to
go back to the trailer occasionally
because i i couldn't sustain a whole day
that kind of energy of being that
buoyant all that yeah because you want
to be fun
you want the director see i love having
him on set the producers love this guy
and he's good
like you want everybody to like you and
then you're just like yeah
yeah oh my god i'm alone it's also like
god that's part of the fun for me still
i i've never been one of those actors
that like
i you know the reason i do this is the
craft and like
i love it i love every aspect of it but
one of my favorite parts of it um
is just the the social aspect still
i mean like yeah it's the reason i got
into it in high school
uh after football didn't work out and
wrestling and
and it's and it's the reason i continue
to love it i love being
around creative people and i love being
around the camera department i just yeah
i don't know that's still
such a huge and my perception of you in
fact was always
you were like the life of when i started
out in the
early 2000s late 90s you i would always
hear
your name in the context of um certainly
somebody who's funny
um but but that kind of the life of the
party
oh rosie oh yeah you got to meet
roseanne there's always
there's always i feel like a party at
your house yeah gina phillips i remember
was like ah
she was the first time i heard your name
was one of my the first jobs i did
with gina and and then nikki all these
people that i knew all these girls
usually girls who were like oh rosie's
the best and he's always have
i'm sure i've been i remember being at
parties at your house
epicenter of you know yeah you know it's
weird it's like i always
felt like i think i've been with that my
family it's like this is what we're
doing i'm organizing a family event or
i'm organizing a
like tonight for instance tonight i'm
having bingo for 30 friends on zoom
everybody's doing that that's cool
everybody's venmo me 10 bucks
and we have four games we do a regular
bingo
a y and x in squares and i will be like
b4 and i got a buddy who's like before
and we just have fun everybody gets a
cocktail
so i like people having fun and i used
to say [ __ ] i'm tired
i used to get so frustrated with myself
why are you putting so much energy
why do you give so much to so many
people and they don't give back anything
it's like well then don't do it
unless you [ __ ] like doing it dude if
it's just part of you to do this stuff
do it because you like it well so you
did you have to check in with yourself
everyone's wanting to just make sure
that you're
enjoying yourself and not just like
facilitating the joy of others
sure and i remember one time my uh my
uncle said something i was at disney
world they used to treat my
whole family to disney world when i was
making real money on you know
back in the day and i take 20 people and
put them up
and vip guides and i used to film it all
and my uncle's like
hey mike why don't you put the camera
down and actually
just live live in the moment here huh
and
it kind of like it's not that upset me i
think it upset me because it was true it
was like
yeah what am i doing yeah yeah i'm
trying to create memories but i'm
this is a memory right now like you know
it's funny mike when you asked me like
what's something upsetting that i've
read about myself about
on instagram i i'm now trying to like
i'm going over any
i'm trying to go through the rolodex of
things that potentially could have upset
me
and i'm not landing on anything but i i
do remember the sensation of
being upset be like being heard offended
whatever and it's usually
has to do with something that strikes a
chord something that maybe is
a little truthful that you find uh
there's some
you know this is valid it's valid
hurtful criticism whatever it is oh yeah
that's usually the stuff that i i um
i had a hard time accepting and and i
think now it's
now i kind of welcome uh
reason i like therapy it's it's um you
know it's a reason why i like
that kind of i'm sure that moment with
your uncle was like uh
there's something there's something very
valuable in that yeah hey do me a favor
lower your head a little or can you
you're almost out of camera well you're
fine there oh that's bad oh
man the second part of this interview i
could really see your face man
by the way you look thank god you still
look young you look like you did when i
saw you in jeepers creepers which i
really liked
oh please i'm telling you oh please that
was from hollywood squares there was a
guy named paul lynn
yeah sure and they used to go let's go
to paul and paul why did the queen
dissolve
members of parliament well maybe she
does magic tricks
remember him good yeah do you ever want
to be a talk show host
do you think he'd ever do that a host um
i think it's easier for me to be a host
than to be on the show which this isn't
is an example of um yeah i like
facilitating a conversation but i don't
necessarily like
having to carry a conversation yeah
yeah i i would like to do that i i don't
know if i would ever do it um
but i think whatever part of me enjoys
that i
i get to scratch that itch by doing the
podcast i don't think yeah i don't have
more of
more any more aspirations than that well
i think you could do a mission to
have my own you know yeah i think you
could do anything you want these days i
mean you know
i thought you know i'd like to be a talk
show host you know i
i just it's it's it's weird it's all
these little clicks you know it's
definitely
definitely clicky like you have to be i
don't know these little inside groups to
get that kind
of thing you know it seems like it could
be a lot of pressure um
i wouldn't want to do it yeah every
night doing that and say oh my god you
never sleep
and doing like you know timely stuff and
current of you staying up to date with i
talking about people in the news i i
don't think i
i am equipped to do that i don't i don't
think i'd be capable of that
uh um i just don't think i'm funny
enough either i mean you you really have
to be
i admire those guys tremendously oh my
god fallon
he's got a family he's constantly doing
sketches on
line he's got this it's like i couldn't
do that i don't know how you have the
energy are you
coked up every night are you on speed
all day how are you doing this
i know mike we're two like single
relatively single guy we don't have
families i
just doing this that's like you know
that's enough this feels that's enough i
would just do this
oh my gosh you do do you love acting as
much as you did do you feel like
it's something you want to do forever do
you feel like i don't know i kind of
lost my
feeling for it that's a really good
question and it's something i've thought
about
a lot lately uh i don't
i don't think i love it in the way where
i need to be doing it constantly like i
i used to i i there was a time where i
um and i think the reason i did a lot of
i don't say movies i shouldn't have done
but like i i don't regret any of the
movies i did i i
even though i did a lot of bad movies i
i just i don't
because i i really enjoyed doing it i
loved as i said i loved
being on sets i loved um i loved going
from these
one town to the next and living out of a
suitcase uh i love that lifestyle
um but i think it's the lifestyle now
that i don't
i i don't i don't enjoy as much as i
used to
i i like having a little bit more
stability
though i don't have a family i i'd like
to one day
um and and the idea of
going from job to job
that part of it doesn't appeal to me
anymore what would you do would you just
do your podcast and maybe try to
do something on the side occasionally i
mean if you if you didn't want to act
what would it be i i mean i love doing
this i mean i found so much joy in this
i've loved uh i
used to love drawing and i just got a
drafting board there are things i love
gardening i
i'm setting up a garden i don't know i'm
finding
and i hate saying this because this time
is so
it's bringing so much pain to so many
people but um
i'm finding myself uh
enjoying things that i that i that i
just hadn't
uh allowed myself to indulge in in the
pad like gardening
like uh you know taking care of my own
lawn i mean i know that sounds so
douchey and privileged but i i am
i i don't know i've been enjoying
reading again and learning a language i
i don't know acting to me i miss it um
it just slowed you down this
inadvertently
slowed you down but in a way where you
could do the things that you've been
wanting to do maybe for a while
subconsciously i hate even admitting
that because it's um
i i you know as i'm doing these things
i'm also
i'm i'm aware of the reality for most
people we're we're in
yeah we get to be in nice homes doing
this fun
thing we get to do this you don't know
where i am you don't know where i am
this could be the only room i'm in
that's true this is gonna be the first
time
right there making assumptions you don't
know me justin it's really funny if this
is the one room you had and you have
like a big jerk poster
and there's a toilet that uh right out
of cameras yeah i just say i'm gonna
take a piss real quick
and i'm just pissing right off camera
you're just connected to a catheter
um i know i having said that i
you know what i really miss is being uh
doing theater i miss being on stage i
um but i i loved my brother and i just
made a movie we directed our first movie
and um we had made a bunch of shorts and
as stressful as it was it was it was so
fulfilling it was so
um creatively satisfying and we're
editing it now and
and it's just been such a satisfying
process creatively that i i don't feel
like i'm i'm i don't feel that sense of
like i'm climbing the walls to to do
another acting job like i used to feel
uh and
and i'm also older i've slowed down
physically i
so i just i don't know i i don't i don't
have that there was a time where i like
i
if i didn't have a job for a week i
would start getting antsy you know um
and i and i
and i took a lot of jobs because just
like they were jobs right
inside of you is brought to you by
better help
online counseling listen up folks
especially with the
with these times uh we all struggle i
don't care who you are we all struggle
with stress and anxiety and you know
this isolation uh
doesn't help we get depressed we don't
know why are we acting like this why
we don't understand it i mean it's
pretty obvious but
your body physiologically thinks
differently it starts to go well
why am i feeling this way you can't
figure it out you don't even know why
you're feeling a certain way and
uh you're not alone i'll tell you that i
have experience
i'm telling you right now you're not
alone um better help
offers online licensed professional
counselors who can help you better help
counselors specialize in in
everything you can imagine uh stress
related anxiety relationships family
matters lgbt
issues grief self-esteem self-esteem
connect with your counselor in a safe
and private online environment anything
you share
is confidential you just fill out a
questionnaire to help
assess your needs and get matched with a
counselor in less than 24 hours
easily schedule secure video or phone
sessions with your therapist
plus exchange unlimited messages and if
for any reason you're unhappy with your
counselor or you just
you can request a new one no charge
you can get professional help when you
want
wherever you want better help is a truly
affordable option
and our listeners get 10 off your first
month with a discount code
inside so why not get started today
go to betterhelp.com inside
that's betterhelp.com
inside talk to a therapist online and
get help
now let me ask you this you know it's
funny because we're both single
i'm 47 you're 41 right yeah that's
really comforting to hear actually well
it's comforting too but also you know
people might say oh you know they're
perpetually single and they're
ladies you know what ladies man or
whatever and they go out with girls and
they just can't settle down and they
just can't and they
you know and there's probably truth to
all of it there's probably truth to all
of it but what
now i don't i read somewhere that you
you you've proposed before
right i propose but you've wanted to get
married to someone
right um or would they read yeah yeah i
mean i look back
at uh yeah i would say there's somebody
that i probably
should have proposed to but i yeah
but but yeah there's somebody i would
say
yeah like i hate to indulge in that
cliche of like like the one who got away
but um
but if it's true yeah yeah yeah i think
it's true
yeah i suppose so i just um i they're
i go back and forth mike there there are
times where i like i do have moments
where i think
oh i should because i love kids i really
love kids and i and i
and it's hard now to be away from you
know because we're quarantined
i don't get to be around my my nephews
um
and i really miss that and
i think oh did i miss the boat and
i i should i i have those moments where
where i i
i'm like regret regretting not having
kids but um
but then you know those those come and
go and then you think well
that reality it's easy to like to
fantasize about something like that but
the reality of having kids i
i don't know if that right now would fit
into i also really enjoy
my life now i don't have um
i don't i don't feel like i i have this
deep void um
i don't know i mean it talked to me in a
year it might change well do you do you
pick yourself apart or
on the other hand do you find that the
older you get
like when people get married younger
they're not as picky
they're kind of like oh they don't do
you think as we get older we go out with
more people we're even more picky we're
like uh
red flag yeah they got that yeah we're
gonna be alone forever oh absolutely
do i see more have i gotten pickier
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean i i
look back at um i mean i would say
if i regret anything it's staying in
staying in relationships that i i knew
at a certain point weren't that won
you know there weren't like the the the
one that i i
should stay in i i regret staying in
those too long and that's
i think that's as simple as um my own
guilt i i have a tremendous you know and
not to blame it all in my upbringing but
i i do have a tremendous like guilt
complex and um
and so i i i think that's a mistake
i i i desperately want to avoid
is getting into the wrong thing and so i
think that's the
reason i'm probably still single sure
there's
fear it's probably some fear fear yeah
it's always fear
most things are feeling it's compounded
every year that goes by and and
i'm 41 now uh you're 47 so it's at the
point where like
i don't want to get into frivolous
things i don't want to get into things
that
you know when we were in our 20s it was
yeah you could date somebody for a
period of time and then you go off and
do a movie and things come between you
and distance and all that um
and and now it's harder to be frivolous
and i don't want to be
frivolous with people's time other
people yeah it's not the thing like you
know what i don't want to waste your
time i
you probably want to have kids i think
you know you deserve somebody better
it's almost like we're pushing people
away
well it's inadvertently yeah i i mean
it's also like i i don't think i was
ready to have kids
um when i was in some of these
relationships and and
i just think they were the wrong ones i
mean the one i regret is is um
it at the time it felt it didn't feel
like the right thing and it was an angel
which relationship was it justin
was um it was one that like i
i it's hard to it's hard to ever regret
that like that because people
in the moment it wasn't i i stand by the
fact that it wasn't right and i hate
even talking about this because
it's weird to talk about something
cryptically and it's not interesting to
people listening
it's incredibly interesting because it's
kind of like you're
what you're feeling i see what you're
feeling and it's it's it's human i you
know look you don't have to
also you know we're inside we're here
with our i've been with my thoughts a
lot more than i usually am i'm more
vulnerable
yeah i'm sorry inside of
it's funny though i think one of my
hang-ups is um
i start a couple things happen
um i start getting self-conscious
i think mostly because i find that kind
of stuff i
find it um not as a listener but
as a the recipient of that to be
indulgent you know like um
oh you know i'm why am i single
and i i think like i think i start
getting
paranoid that people listening
um you know and like what that's my own
stuff to work through and
i i just i just being paranoid that it's
not
it's not at all interesting however you
saying something that
you know got away or something that to
me that just sounds like something that
you know hey
from my heart as something got away that
didn't
come to fruition like and that's all
that yeah that's the only only important
information from that
it's um and it's i never thought i
mean you know that's a cliche for a
reason the one that got away
and you hear that and you think but i
never felt that
until um uh until you felt it until you
feel it
and and and it's it's a real thing but
it's um
it's not necessarily a bad thing because
i think it it just means that i'm in a
different place and that person's in a
different place and um
right you know uh do you have anything
like that do you have the
regrets like yeah [ __ ] yeah i mean
there's
there are moments where i look back and
i go i was just [ __ ]
you know i was immature or i was uh you
know not that i'm not mature now but
yeah sure man there's there's moments
where i'm like
i don't know if i have any regrets where
i look at it and go
i should have i could have maybe married
that person
it's not that in fact there i had um on
this other show i did chris sullivan
who's amazing um i interviewed we
interviewed my ex-girlfriend
from years ago who's like my best friend
and she's married to this
wonderful guy i'm unbelievable eric
almost photographer and they have a kid
and we got really i wouldn't listen to
it
but everybody was like you should listen
to it
it's great because it's really if you
feel like you're vulnerable and you feel
and she i remember when she had a baby
i cried i cried and it wasn't because i
was like god that could have been
maybe me at all yeah
it was this is what she's always wanted
yeah she's always wanted a baby she's
such a great mom i knew she'd be a great
mom i knew
so the tears were of joy so i look back
and i'm like yeah
she found the guy that would treat her
with all the respect not that i didn't
respect
the guy that would give her everything
that i couldn't kudos to him
i think that's why i'm hesitating to
even
i'm tiptoeing around even that phrase
the one that got away because
of course the real version of that is
she's happy i mean as long if it's
somebody that you like that you care
about that much that you care about at
all yeah
um there should be no
nothing resembling regret if that person
is still
is happy yeah so yeah i i think it's
sort of a selfish
um it's a selfish brush to
paint yourself with um i'm sure everyone
asks you this but
do you want to be married this stable
relationship do you want to be with
somebody now
uh you know i think my grandmother you
know hearing people saying you know
my friend stacy's saying you'd be such a
great dad and hearing your friends say
you're so good with kids and you are a
kid and they can relate to you and
hearing your grandma saying mikey
family's the best thing there is
i think overall this all this time it
torments you
and it it sort of makes you go i i know
i should be doing this why am i not
doing this and then you start to feel
what's wrong with me and then you start
to think
now i'm too old what am i going to do i
can't you know what am i going to do
when i wake up and i change your diaper
i'm going to take care of someone
i don't want the kid i want a kid to be
smart and who's going to teach him math
i'm not
i'm not the guy and i start thinking
about all these things that this kid's
going to
fail he's going to fail with a child
father like me unless i date a [ __ ]
si like a a you know a nasa like
genius scientist no no get out
that's how my mind works yeah yeah so i
think you know
why do that why put a kid in the world
when you just can't
you know but i at the same time do i
want to be alone the rest of my life no
do i want to find some
i don't want to find someone just to uh
you know what i guess i won't be alone
right well that's selfish yeah yeah i
think about that too i i do
and that's that's the selfish question
that i wrestle with which is
and this is really morbid but um when
you're leaving the world
when you're dead when you're dying uh it
would ease
that i feel like it would probably ease
the
transition yeah yeah you know if you die
with
some sort of lineage and but that's
selfish i mean like
i i you know if if there was somebody in
my life if there was a woman who i
i loved and wanted to um
you know of course i would want of kids
i i just that's
a it's a huge thing especially when you
consider
this the life i lead right now it
doesn't
feel like it's missing that is that
i don't feel like i i don't feel like
i'm wanting for anything and part of
that has been my own privilege you know
i
i'm i'm privileged and and i have the
you know if this if this pandemic has
has
really highlighted anything it's it's
those that are
you know the haves and the have-nots i
mean it's really like
it's i think it's shining a light on on
the
socio-economic injustices and so and
it's making me feel
that much more grateful to be um
privileged
so i think i don't feel like i'm
certainly now i don't feel like i'm
wanting for anything i feel so
[ __ ] blessed to to have the life i
have
sure um it's also hard to meet people in
quarantine
it is do you think that people who don't
want kids for the most part
maybe it may sound bad and the word is
kind of
do you think it's because we're just
selfish it might be i mean maybe it's
just like you know what i
i want my time to be for me and maybe
yeah maybe a girlfriend and maybe like
but i don't wanna maybe being selfish is
actually
being good because you're not bringing
someone in the world that you [ __ ]
can't give that attention to
which i'm not going to say anything
we've seen versions of that i mean my
mom i love my mom
people i haven't talked about this but
like my mom
you know she had kids she was pregnant
she was 16 then 18 then she had me when
she was 23
and my dad was 18 and a hippie and it's
like
but she always wanted to be the center
of attention she never got her childhood
it was taken away by having children
so what happened she still wanted to be
the center of attention
and i don't want to ever ever cause i
would it would
[ __ ] ruin me if i couldn't give that
kid every bit of attention
that he or she deserved and that would
burn me but michael
you know that you're in a much i
completely understand this
psychology behind that and that fear and
your mom being arrested in development
but you know that you've already
far surpassed whatever position she was
in in life i mean
you're far more developed than she was
and
maybe a little no i i think i mean like
any of the hang-ups that you have are
the result of your
of what it hap what happened to her in
your own childhood but um
but god that's crazy 16 16 and 18. oh
boy i got so many stories
so you weren't kidding when you said you
thought they
you're the fact that you weren't growing
was duty their their drug intake
no no no my my you know yeah i mean i'm
sure my dad were hippies they were real
hippies well i don't know real hippies
but you know my dad was like you know
at 18 years old when he's you know i
think he had me when he was 19.
wow 19 or 20 the latest lucky they're
young still they're young my dad's 67 my
mom's 72.
so oh my god they're still together no
no no my mom's in her
third marriage because my dad was her
second my
dad's divorced twice my sisters in her
fourth marriage
my brother adam's only been married once
so far my brother eric never he'll never
get married
against two brothers uh i have a half
older brother uh what do you call a
biological brother
wow i guess a half older sister and then
i have two younger half sisters with my
dad's previous
so your idea of family and
marriage it's it was always very
fractured always dysfunctional always
crazy nobody talks to anybody i can
i mean honestly if you ever have me on
your show i'll tell you all this [ __ ]
oh i would love that i mean well no
wonder this
this must be so therapeutic for you this
is what this is this is therapy and
hopefully some people can relate and go
oh my god
so what do you think of somebody when
you hear that i had my parents are still
together
they were loving i mean you know
sometimes
sometimes too loving sometimes there are
hang-ups it's not perfect but
what do you think of when you hear that
story
you [ __ ] [ __ ] you stupid [ __ ]
no i honestly go thank god
that's good that's good that's nice that
you had that you know and by the way
i don't sit here and you know i'm not
knocking my parents i'm just the more i
yeah and the more
i'm forgetting i'm very forgiving i'm
like it's taken me a long time but the
more you could say
this is how it was they did the best
they could that's all they knew
and it's not an excuse it's how i feel
it's like you aren't capable
you couldn't do it and that's that and
you know what
i got what i got and now i'm working on
me and i have a lot of i've had success
and i'm able to love and i'm able to you
know sure
it must be very hard to let that go
though
i don't know you're somebody i've always
really like liked and i like that spirit
that you have this gregarious
you have bingo parties for people and
you want to bring people together and
you have damage from your parents who
through no fault of your own did this
thing to you and i don't know i'm just
always rooting for you you know i i
thanks dude well you know you too i mean
look when you say
my parents did to me i don't look at it
that way you know they were young
maliciously no no no i think they did
the best they could and i think that you
know there were some good moments and
there was some
you know you could always i don't
compare but you can say you know some
many people have had it way worse many
people have way better i'm just saying
all that matters it doesn't matter what
people try to tell you or explain to you
like
what you didn't have this you had a hat
roof over your head
as a child in your developmental stages
you know what you had and didn't have
because it's the way
you are it's the way you feel it's the
way you think it's the way you felt
right and no one can tell you what they
did
when you didn't feel that way so you can
forgive and you can do this
but you know i've had many conversations
with people's like why would you feel
that way
you know if you say i hurt my let's say
you're dating a girl i've had a
situation where i'm like
you know you said that i just want to
let you know that it hurt my feelings
when you said that
why why would that hurt your feelings
that should never be the way they take
that they should always say
first of all i'm sorry i did not mean to
hurt your feelings but can you explain
to me why
this is why i think a lot of marriages
get ruined because people are so
sensitive and they get like
they can't just say it's really
triggered there's triggers why can't you
just say
i remember saying things to people like
why are you
how could i have meant that why would i
have meant that and then you get upset
and you're like guilty of that
and they didn't need that all they
needed you to say was i'm sorry you feel
that way and i'm sorry that i made you
feel that way and that's not what i
meant but you felt it and it's real and
i apologize and that's totally
[ __ ] what you should do yeah my i
it's
i think it's so valuable to recognize
your own triggers and your own
limitations and and
i've been recognizing my own i i uh
yeah i i think when somebody's illogical
when somebody's
not the behavior is not making sense it
doesn't necessarily mean it's
wrong and that was something that i i
think i grew up thinking if it's not
logical it's it's wrong and when it
comes to
you know people's feelings and their
triggers and these things we're talking
about
it's not necessarily always logical i
have a very hard time with that
uh so you're gonna tell me you're gonna
tell me who this girl was or what
well it's one of what one of probably
three that i people could
think of i don't think so no no i don't
think it's somebody that people
no no yeah yeah [ __ ] all right here
we go ashley t and these
these should be quick ashley t good old
ashley t
top tier [ __ ] talking do you still
practice the five d's of dodgeball do i
still practice the 5ds of dodgeball
i haven't played dodgeball in a while um
what were the 5ds again
somebody sent me a meme that was like a
corona virus
meme that was um that was like dodge
whatever they are dodge duck dip dive
and um
and they were like you should you should
uh post this
and uh i i felt like i
felt very strange about um
making light of it so i didn't but i um
that was the last time i remember
hearing that uh dodge duck dip duck god
you know i i'm so grateful to have
talked about gratitude i'm grateful to
have worked with
some really good actors and riptorn was
uh
one of them hang on a second what is he
doing over there what is he he's running
around i heard that interview where
you were messing around a rip turn was
in a close-up of his shot and he he just
was like what the [ __ ] is justin long
doing what happened to do that quickly
no no no he said um yeah i was really
nervous around him i
[ __ ] by the way your listeners um
riptorn is one of the greats you know i
mean he's
he was one of tennessee williams like
favorite actors and he was in the
in the original sweet bird of youth and
like he just didn't
yeah there's a great movie called payday
uh
have you seen payday great plays like a
wayland jennings type
country singer [ __ ] great man he i
was just such a big fan of his
and um and so you know but he was a
little
uh whatever this is not he was a little
ornery
and um and so we were doing the scene
where he threw the
the wrench at my head and and and he
was forgetting his lines um
and he was looking around and i've
experienced this before i'm sure you
have with with
older actors and i pray to god it
doesn't happen to me but but
i'm sure it will where you start
forgetting your life i forget them now
but go ahead
yes yeah that's true well and oh i'm
just going to turn the light on
um and and one of two things can happen
where either you
you you take it upon yourself to you own
it you're like oh [ __ ] i'm forgetting my
lines or
you you blame it on somebody else you
know i'm forgetting my lines because of
this
right um and so he uh
i was doing my off camera for him it was
his coverage
and um he threw like the prop wrench
near me
and i made it like it hit my face and i
kind of
i didn't want to do too much because i
didn't want to be distracting uh
and he said he just forgot his lines and
he and he looked at me and he said
what are you doing you're dancing around
like a goddamn monkey what is he doing
and i at first i thought he was an ad
living i thought he was improvising so i
was i kind of tried to stay in it a
little bit and um he goes cod cot
he's dancing around like a goddamn
monkey you know and uh
i was so nervous i said uh afterwards i
said
i i tried to apologize and i said i'm
really sorry um
mr torn and he said let me tell you
something son when you talk open other
actors lines
it means they got to go loop the whole
goddamn thing
and i said oh oh i wasn't i wasn't
talking
you thought i was talking i wasn't
talking and uh
and he goes are you calling me a liar
and i said no i'm
you know what what do you say when
somebody jesus
just say i just backed down and that was
it he
he i think he was had just forgotten the
lines but he was um
sometimes you want somebody to blame
it's like christian bale no i'm [ __ ]
doing something
no do i [ __ ] mess with what you're
doing you know i gotta tell you
i don't i don't totally blame christian
babies i love christian bales but i
don't know
it won't talk too long here's what i
would have done if i flipped that and i
was having a bad day
dude shut the [ __ ] up right right or i'm
gonna flip
out and then that's it of course i
wouldn't do that
for 20 minutes passive aggressive right
and like a [ __ ]
but i i i don't totally totally blame
him
i know because from what i understand
the guy was moving [ __ ] around
christian bale is in this whatever it's
hard to defend
that level of iran but um
he's an intense guy he cares about his
work people let it go he's still working
all right
let's we're gonna do quick fire here
boom pat
what moment would be on the blooper reel
of your life my life oh man
you know i think about that a lot i
there so many times things happen to me
where i think um
oh god i'd like to or not not
necessarily to me or the
friend's mind where i think oh god i
would love to see that in the afterlife
you know that that movie defending your
life
the albert brooks movie um i i think
about that movie a lot in
when when funny things happen um because
i think like
you know in that movie they they
actually review moments of
somebody's life they get to rewind them
and watch them back
uh and i think i think about that a lot
like oh god i'd like to if this
if i could see if i could relive 10
moments um
god offhand i i don't know um
i i remember almost walking into traffic
once i i
i was talking about um i was on a street
corner in new york and i was talking
about that movie
hamilton oh that took the play uh it had
just come out and i
it was just nominated for a bunch of
tony's and i said to my friends
uh oh good for lin-manuel miranda it's
really cool it's his first thing and it
gets nominated for all these tonys and
and
uh they said oh no no he did just play
in the heights
then he's been nominated so he's already
and i go oh
so and i i this is word for word i said
oh so he's no stranger to the tony scene
which is a crazy thing for me to say for
anyone to say but it's weird for me to
say
and i kind of like i tend to drift
around i i
i like looking up and looking at the sky
and stuff and i kind of drifted into
off the curb um and a
bus came i it was so close to hitting me
like a speeding bus that i remember
feeling my hair i have kind of like
floppy hair and i remember feeling like
my hair like hit the butt i'm sure it
didn't but it felt it was so close to
hitting me
tear down a friend of mine pulled me
back and they were like what the [ __ ]
are you doing
and they were freaked out i i like i
didn't see how close it was to hitting
me but it was really close
and um and my brother and i were
laughing about that because my last
words would have been
oh so he's no stranger to the tony scene
that line and and they would have had to
tell my parents
i'm so you know or his last
oh he said he's no stranger to the tony
scene well what does that mean
yeah i think about that a lot whenever i
say anything like that similar to that
like similarly embarrassing
uh my brother and i we say oh here here
comes the meteor
here comes the asteroid that's it
your last words all right here we go
jennifer n what would be your dream role
in a horror movie
you know what you play the victim once
uh it's hard to find different
versions of that um i don't know i don't
know it's a good question but i
can you know be fun i love nightmare and
elm street be fun to do a
nightmare on elm street just to be in
one of those just to be with like robert
england yeah
dude i would love that samantha m is
there
a particular genre of movie you prefer
acting in um
excuse me uh lately it's been i really
miss doing i want to do a comedy like a
real
uh like a goofy
fun comedy right those are the ones that
i've been
watching a lot of and and you know i
keep looking at the jerk that poster
um and as i said earlier i
only recently saw that and that kind of
dumb
it's so rare like really smart dumb
humor is my favorite uh oh yeah i think
it's my favorite genre like like
mike judge type stuff yeah well you did
idiocracy idiocracy is
yeah that type of that
all right last one sean double you ever
get baked with kevin smith
yeah yeah i mean every time you go over
his house he has uh
have you been you know kevin no i mean
we know each other he's come up to me at
conventions and
talk to me about guardians and this and
i've been trying to get on the podcast
the [ __ ]
you know i i yeah i don't have his
numbers
i had a small part in guardians 2 i
played uh martin x which coincidentally
was one of the original guardians in the
comics from
that stan lee did but uh i threw three
little scenes i had uh they cgi'd my
face with dots remember the stallone but
it was cool it was fun to see the second
one mike i i got to see that yeah
just look look next to stallone i'm the
guy with diamonds on his face oh that's
the stallone one
oh my god well dude look man i honestly
this is awesome i i really didn't know
you other than
seeing you every once in a while or
hearing about you but i always liked you
oh well i was trying to remember how do
we we know each other from
was it is it gina or nikki acogs is
nikki acox probably
nikki yeah yeah i did a movie years ago
that no one should ever see
uh i don't want to talk about it oh come
on no
no no it doesn't matter it was called
rave macbeth we had
they lost the sound so we had to loop
the entire yeah
we had to loop the entire movie and
what's funny it was it actually was
really cool and different until we had
to loop the movie imagine
doing adr every line yeah you have to
say all of the dialogue why because
it was something they lost the sound
something happened man it was i i didn't
even go there was like a premiere for i
was like [ __ ] yeah i'm not going to that
[ __ ]
oh my god i'm not embarrassing myself i
was just like you know this is just not
good it's like i put my heart and soul
on this i didn't get paid much for it
and then you lose the sound i don't want
to [ __ ] i'm lou i spent
weeks doing i was the lead so i had to
do weeks of doing the adr
oh my god was it was it macbeth though i
mean was the story of macbeth
yeah i mean it was like loosely in a
drug world kind of like you know a
witchy kind of
if it wasn't looped and if it was like
there was things wrong with it but it
had potential it just
they were making a lot of movies then i
remember there were a lot of like drug
fueled like that movie spun or uh
go you know movies right right around
then right yes yeah and this is
its own little sub genre yeah and i shot
this in germany so it was uh that's
right i remember yes yes i met the girl
named barbarian
was she in there yup she was in that
margaret marguerite
monroe um kirk baltz kirk baltimore's
the guy who got his ear
cut off in uh reservoir dogs great actor
yeah
so he and i yeah we still talk about
that everyone said well text me you know
wow mike i you know i would love for you
to be on the show because i've
now i feel like i have so many questions
well let's do it let me know let me know
when oh come on of course
that'd be great thank you for allowing
me to be inside of you my friend justin
and
i was a pleasure to have you inside let
me know when you want me to come on and
we'll do it i love that mike yeah yeah
and
i you know i can't wait for this to be
over it'd be nice to see you
out there who do you think he was
thinking about
i kept thinking is he talking about drew
barrymore is he talking about so
yeah i don't know i wasn't i wasn't
interrogating the guy i love him
i just you know i wanted to i wanted to
know some
[ __ ] thank you again to uh everyone
remember
uh new hoodies uh inside of you hoodies
black shirts and gray shirts they'll be
up on the site very shortly so keep
looking
remember to go to amaze.com reunion to
win a an entry into a virtual tour with
or a virtual room with me
tom uh wellington kristen kruege of
smallville
to support the ronald mcdonald house uh
new patreon
john heater and i are just doing a
patreon exclusive so you have to just be
a patron
member it's called our our patreon is
called
where have all the good horror movies
gone and take a look at that
see if you want to join it uh it's it'll
be a lot of fun john and i are
we have a good dynamic here's a fan
letter
from jason i've been a fan of years ever
since smallville and i recently
discovered your podcast a few months ago
and i cannot stop listening i'm sure you
receive
hundreds of these and i am not even sure
if you will read this however i just
want to say thank you
i want to write to you for a while i've
wanted to and the words never made sense
to me
your podcast has given me a lot lately
short backstory i'm 27 married
two kids and work uh and work a
commission
sales job selling furniture i have a lot
of unanswered questions growing up even
more than ever
why am i the way i am will i ever become
successful
am i meant for something else why am i
constantly
talking myself out of opportunities why
do i have anxiety depression does it
make me weird
is my parents actions and how they
raised me going to affect my kids
i know i'm a complete stranger and you
have no idea who i am i may never have a
chance to meet you or shake your hand or
get a picture with you but i
just have to say thank you your podcast
has saved me
i don't feel so alone because even
though there's about 20 years between us
i feel like i
have so much to relate with you and your
guests
i've looked at my past differently i
tried to change the way i am in my
marriage how i
parent my kids i've been able to look
at life a little differently knowing i'm
not alone and i am not the only one that
struggles with some of these
issues i am not a patron
yet hopefully financial i can
financially i can get
get it together and start giving back
for what you've given me
buddy you just listening to the show and
getting something from this
is enough don't you even worry about
that thank you again for everything i
look forward to every tuesday
by the way batman vs superman would have
been made so much more money if you
relax
i would love to hear back from you if
not just know
in auburn georgia you have a huge fan
and you are touching lives coast
to coast the funny thing is i never read
that letter until now
i like to feel something and you know i
could always cut it if the letter is
absurd or someone yells at me and tells
me to f off but
i like to read it and feel it and i felt
it for sure
and um you're not alone man jason you're
not alone you'll never be alone
i think that's a mentality that you know
sometimes people feel they're alone and
they just keep distancing themselves but
you have to just
be aware of those things and you know
you're doing the best you can
and the way you were parented that you
know you got to break the
break the cycle if you didn't if you
weren't raised well by your parents
you have to be the man that you want to
become and you can't blame i have family
members that you know
and we've all done it we blame we blame
our father or our mother or
this or the relationship or someone
break up broke up with me they ruined my
life no
you've got this is your life it's your
life man
that's it again i'm not a therapist but
it's pretty safe to say this is your
life
so you have to take responsibility for
your actions
you have to make the necessary changes
to make you the person you want to be
the man you want to be
and that's what i believe and i'm
fighting to do it every day don't think
it's easy
i struggle it all the time i doubt
myself all the time and then i switch
gears i will not allow myself to keep
doing this man
and let's go to these patrons here here
we go
ah i know them all i really know them
all nancy d
we got mary b we got leah s
trisha f sarah v
yukiko jill e brian h
lauren g nico p barry
l angelina g jerry w kevin r emily k
bob b robert b jason w kristen
k is that kristen crook no it's kristen
key i know
sorry andrew c allison l mark a
jason d raj oh yeah baby
joshua d emily hi mlas
cjp you down with cjp yeah you know me
rocks raccoons rocks raccoon
come on girl samantha m humza
b jennifer n stacy b carly t vanessa in
the sky
i always see that name i always remember
vanessa and this guy reem
you know i love your aim jennifer s hey
girl
janelle b neil w you know i know you
and janelle tabbett the 272. kimberly e
melissa c
mike e jake m catherine m jack s
jude d ramirez chris f chad w
leanne we didn't forget you all right
we didn't forget you darling darla w
jackie p rodrigo s hey rodrigo that
sounds like a sexy name
rachel c travis b ray
a ray a
thank you to all my badass patrons we
just did a uh
a live private live patreon youtube
experience saturday that's that was our
third one that's not even part of like
what i offered and i'm doing it because
i just enjoy you guys i enjoy
talking with you i enjoy instagram lives
i enjoy sending messages to patrons i
i just have a lot of fun doing it and
they're so
so awesome i'll leave you with this
um you know as the weeks go on
and the divisiveness continues which
there should be none
you know we should just be i don't get
political on here i hope you can enjoy
that
i appreciate that but um this isn't like
you know i i get it if you're like oh
i'm strong and i'm healthy and i could
do what i want that's great man but it's
not about you it's about
other people who if they get it they
might die you just have to be careful
you know you just have to what why is it
so hard to wear a mask
if you're going to a public place wear a
mask
if not you're just disrespecting
everybody in there you're telling
everybody that you don't care about them
just just try to follow the rules man
just try to help people uh you know
if you don't believe in it just stay
home i'm staying home
but you know when i go i try to i do
wear a mask
i don't know i'm not going to tell you
what to do but i'm telling you what the
[ __ ] to do
wear a mask all right that's it wear a
mask come on is that
that hard you got to rebel it's your
right not to wear a mask
you know it's your right also to help
your fellow human beings and save their
lives and
you know sometimes i read on facebook
some of my friends from back home
chase ass i try not to respond
yeah love thy neighbor man truly love
thy neighbor
but listen i love you guys thank you so
much for listening we got a great
episode next week
i think you're gonna really dig it i
mean you're digging all of them but uh
keep listening keep listening even if
you don't uh like the guests or
know the guest you'll learn something i
promise thank you
oh thank you to ryan for the wonderful
editing job
thank you bryce for uh your constant
work as well
and uh devotion to the podcast not like
i'm paying these guys millions of
dollars to do this
right now they're shaking their head
like no he's not but
um i really appreciate it and i i always
say you know hopefully this thing
takes off more and more and we were able
to
make it worthwhile for everybody but i
hope everybody's really enjoying the
podcast
and getting something from it i really
feel like everybody is and that's the
most important thing
we talk about not comparing ourselves i
really don't it's it's not comparing i
just want uh i want this thing to blow
up bigger that's it
let's get just let's just grow it
together all right thank you so much
um for for listening thank you for
allowing me to be inside each and every
one of you
and uh over there too and right there
and right there and right there i love
you thank you next week we got a great
uh
episode coming up um so please listen